in grappling with the climate problem as
a journalist I paid too much attention
to climate scientists
that's why all my articles focused on
climate change and it was 2006 I
remember now pretty clearly I
I was asked by the week in review
section of the New York Times to write a
sort of a weekend thumb sucker we call
them on um you know you're sitting the
suck yourself and think about something
why is everybody so pissed off about
climate change it was after Al Gore's
movie The Al Gore movie came out
Inconvenient Truth hurricane Katrina's
big senator inhofe in the Senate from
Oklahoma wasn't yet throwing snowballs
but it was close to that and so I looked
into what was going on why is this so
heated in 2006 the story is called
Yelling fire on hot planet
and that was the first time this is
after 18 years of writing about global
warming
that was the first time I interviewed a
social scientist not a climate scientist
her name is Helen Ingram she's the UC
Irvine
and she laid out for me the factors that
determine why people vote or what they
vote for what they think about
politically
and they were the antithesis of the
climate problem
she used the words she said people go in
the voting booth
thinking about things that are soon
Salient and certain
and climate change is complex you know
has long time scales and and that really
jogged me and then I between 2006 2010
I started interviewing other social
scientists and I I this was by far the
scariest science of all it's the the
climate in our heads or inconvenient
Minds
and in how that translates into
Political norms and stuff really became
the monster not the not the climate
system is there social dynamics did the
scientists themselves because uh
I've gotten to witness a kind of
flocking Behavior with Scientists so
it's almost like a flock of birds within
the flock
there's a lot of disagreement and fun
debates and everybody trying to prove
each other wrong but they're all kind of
headed in the same direction and you
don't want to be the bird that kind of
leaves that flock no so like there's an
idea that science is a mechanism will
get us towards the truth but it'll
definitely get us somewhere but it could
be not the truth in the short term in
the long term a bigger flock will come
along and it'll get us to the truth but
there's a sense that I don't know if
there's a mechanism within science to
like
snap out of it if you're done the wrong
track usually you get it right but
sometimes you don't when you don't it's
very costly and there's so many factors
that line up to perpetuate that flocking
behavior one is Media attention comes in
the other is funding comes in the
National Science Foundation or whatever
European foundations pour a huge amount
of money into things related to climate
and so you and then you your narrative
in your head is
shaped by that aspect of the climate
problem that's in the spotlight I I
started using this hashtag
a few years back narrative capture like
be wary of narrative capture where
you're
you're on a train and everyone's getting
on the train and this is in the media
too not just science and it becomes self
self-sustaining and
and contrary indications are ignored or
downplayed no one does replication
science because you don't your career
doesn't Advance through replicating
someone else's work so those contrary
indications are are not necessarily you
know really dug in on and this is for
this is Way Beyond climate this is of
many fields you as you said you might
have seen this in Ai and it's really
hard to find it's another form of path
dependency the the term I used for
the breaking narrative capture to me
for me has come mostly
from stepping back
and reminding myself of the basic
principles of Journalism
journalism's basic principles are useful
for anybody
confronting a big enormous Dynamic
complex thing is
who what where when why just be really
rigorous about not assuming because
there's a fire in Boulder County or a
flood in Fort Myers that climate which
is in your head because you're part of
the climate team at the New York Times
or whatever
is the front
is the foreground part of this problem
what's the psychological challenge of
that
if you incorporate the fact that if you
uh try to step back and have Nuance you
might get attacked by the others in the
flock oh I was right well you you've
certainly been to both of you get
attacked yeah continuously from
different sides so let me just ask about
that how does that feel and how do you
continue thinking clearly
and uh continuously try to have humility
and step back and not get defensive in
in that on as a communicator I I mean
there are other things happening at the
same time right I'm now 35 years into
almost 40 years into my journalism
career so I have some Independence I'm
free from the obligations of
you know don't really need my next
paycheck I live in Maine now in a house
I love I own it outright it's a great
privilege and honor and
um as a result of a lot of hard work and
and so I'm Freer to think freely and I
know my colleagues in newsrooms when I
was at the New York Times in The
Newsroom
you become captive to a narrative just
as you do out in the world
um
the New York Times had a narrative about
the about Saddam Hussein
drove us into
that war the times sucked right into
that and helped perpetuate it
um I think we're in a bit of a narrative
we the media my friends at the times and
others are on a train ride on climate
change depicting it in a certain way
that really I saw problems with how they
handled the Joe manchin issue in America
the the West Virginia senator they
really kind of piled on and zoomed in on
his Investments
which is really important to do but they
never pulled back and said by the way
he's
a rare species he's a democrat in West
Virginia and which is he'll be other
otherwise occupied by a republican
there'll be no talk of a climate deal or
any of that stuff without him and but
when you once you're starting to kind of
frame a story in a certain way you
carried along and as you said sometimes
it breaks in a new Norm arrives but
the climate train is still kind of
rushing forward and missing
the opportunity to cut it into its
pieces
and say well what's really wrong with
Florida
and it's for me when you ask about how I
handle the slings and arrows and stuff
it's it's partially because I'm fast
worrying about it too much
um I mean it was pretty intense 2009
Rush Limbaugh
suggested I kill myself on his radio
show it's a really great what was that
about I had this is actually this was a
meeting in Washington
in 2009 on population at the Wilson
Center
I couldn't be there so actually this is
pre-covered but I was zooming in or
something like Skyping in
and I was talking about
in a playful way I said Well if you
really want to worry about carbon this
is during the debate over uh carbon tax
model for a bill in America
we should probably uh have a carbon tax
for kids because a bigger family in
America is a big source of more
emissions it was kind of a playful
thought bubble some right-wing blogger
blogged about it it got into Russia's
you know pile of things to talk about
and and the clip is really fun uh also
meaning so uh if humans well he's not
bad for the environment uh we can I can
imagine
that's how you know you've made it
explicit he said Mr revkin of the New
York Andrew rev kind of the New York
Times if you really think that people
are the worst thing that ever happened
to this planet why do you just kill
yourself and save the planet by dying it
was tough for you it was tough for my
family um you know to me it did generate
some interesting calls and stuff on my
my voicemail and
um but but on the left I was also
undercut Roger Pilkey Jr a prominent
researcher of climate risk and climate
policy UC Boulder was actively
his career track was
derailed purposefully by people who just
thought his message was too off off the
path when you you know
even dealing with this for a very long
time so look I I just want to get back
to so the science I I don't think the
the science get it so much wrong as it
just becomes accepted to to make certain
assumptions as you just said we we
assume no friction so you know there's
there's a way that you kind of model the
world that ends up being also a
convenient message uh in many ways and I
think the the main convenient message in
climate and it's not surprising if you
think about it uh you know the main
convenient message is that the best way
to do something about all the things
that we call climate is to cut CO2
and that turns out to only sometimes be
true and with with a lot of caveats but
that's sort of the message it takes a
long time yes yes it's really really
difficult to do in any meaningful sort
of time frame uh and and and if you
challenge that you yes you're outside
the flock and you get attacked I've
always uh so uh somebody told me once uh
I think it's true they say it at the uh
Hobart law school if you have a good
case pound the case if you have a bad
case pound the table uh and so I've
always felt that when people go after me
they're kind of pounding to table
they're you know they're literally
screaming I don't have a good case I'm
really annoyed with what you're saying
and and so to me that actually means
it's much more important to make this
argument uh sure I mean I would I would
love you know everyone just saying oh
that's a really good point I'm gonna use
that but yeah uh we're we're stuck in a
situation certainly in a conversation
where
a lot of people invested a lot of time
and energy on saying we should cut
carbon emissions this is the way to help
humankind and and just be clear I think
we should cut carbon emissions as well
but we should also just be realistic
about what we can achieve with that and
what are all the other things that we
could also do uh and it turns out that a
lot of these other things are much
cheaper much more effective will help
much more much quicker and so getting
that point out is just an incredibly
important for us to get it right so in
in some sense you know uh uh to make
sure that we don't do another Iraq and
we don't do another uh you know lots of
stupid decisions I mean this this is one
of the things mankind is very good at uh
and I guess uh I I see my role uh and I
think that's probably also how you see
yourself is trying to you know get
everyone to do it slightly less wrong so
let me ask you about a deep
psychological effect for you there's
also a drug of martyrdom
so whenever you stand against the flock
right no there is uh you wrote
a couple of really good books on the
topic the most recent false alarm
I stand as the holder of Truth
that everybody who is alarmist is wrong
and here's just simple calm way to
express the facts of the matter
and that's very compelling to a very
large number of people they want to make
a martyr out of you
is that are you worried about your own
mind
uh being corrupted by that by enjoying
standing against the crowd no no no
there's there's very little uh I I guess
I can see what you're saying sort of in
a literary way or something poetic here
yeah there's there's very little Comfort
or or sort of usefulness in in in
Annoying a lot of people uh you know it
just it just you know whenever I go to a
party for instance I know that there's a
good chance people are going to be
annoyed with me and I would love that
not to be the case but what I try to do
is you know uh uh so I I try to be very
polite and you know sort of not push
people's buttons unless they they sort
of actively say so you're saying oh kind
of stupid stuff on the climate right uh
and then try to engage with them and say
well what what is it you're thinking
about and hopefully you know during that
party and then it ends up being a really
bad party for me but anyway so I'll I'll
you know I'll end up possibly convincing
one person that I'm not totally stupid
but no I'm I'm not playing the Martyr
and I'm not enjoying that
see it's so interesting
the uh I mean they're the the
um martyr complex is all around the
climate question uh Michael Mann at the
far end of the spectrum of activism from
where Bjorn is uh was a climate
scientist is a climate scientist who uh
was actively attacked by
um inhofe and West in Virginia
politicians and
really abused in many ways he had come
up with a very prominent model of
looking at long-term records of climate
change we've got this hockey stick for
temperature uh and he you know he
definitely sits there in a certain kind
of Spotlight because of that so it's not
unique at any particular vantage point
in the the spectrum of sort of prominent
people on the debate